55 BC and Julius Caesar has just arrived
on the southern coast of Britain he did
this shortly after his conquest of Gaul
which was here he likely did so because
of the close ties between the
inhabitants of Britain known then as
Britannia and bows of Gaul many of the
Gauls who resisted Caesar had alliances
in kinship ties in Britain and some
Gallic neither spread across the channel
whilst others received military
assistance Caesars first landing did not
achieve much but he landed again next
year and after some conflict he secured
the surrender of some British tribes and
was able to exact a yearly tribute as
well the people who lived in Britain at
this time often referred to as Celts
this term isn't particularly useful
since it implies a level of homogeneity
which simply didn't exist the
inhabitants of Britain certainly spoke a
Celtic language but to say that they
were thus all Celtic would be like
calling English because Germans since
English is the Germanic language these
people were divided into tribes and
small kingdoms such as the terrine of
antes who lived here and were Roman
puppets that said cattle Britons are
commonly used terms after the sake of
simplicity their use is warranted but
just remember it's more complicated so
after Caesar had left Britain some of
the tribes had become part of the Roman
world if only barely Romans were now
much more aware of Britain since before
Caesar he had been seen as a near
mythical place which was an ocean away
so over the next century a fair few
changes underwent the Roman Republic
first Caesar became dictator for life
and was subsequently murdered thus
bringing about the civil war which would
see his adopted son Octavian become the
first emperor of Rome the Emperor
Augustus Augustus and his heirs had I
had Britain for invasion of the
following half-century but it was always
sidelined due to more pressing concerns
this didn't change until Cunha Bolinas
the king of the cutter Bologna tribe had
conquered the Treena vantes and expelled
his son Cunha Bolinas his son fled to
the Roman Emperor Gaius better known as
Caligula and declared the submission of
Britain Caligula prepared an invasion
force but at the last minute called it
off shortly before being murdered his
uncle Claudius became Emperor and in
order to cement his reputation with the
people and often rebellious legions he
decided to conquer Britain and achieved
that which his predecessors could not in
43 ad for Roman legions led by a certain
Alice Claudius and their auxiliaries
arrived in Britain about 40,000 men in
total and began the process of
conquering the South the British natives
attempted to resist but in battle they
lacked the heavy armor or the
professionalism of the Roman legionaries
that said the
British resisted fiercely and after four
years Roman control over this much of
the island some such as Kaka dub nurse
who ruled over this area and Prasutagus
who ruled the ice any who lived here
were allied to the Romans and helped
them administer the population in return
for prestige wealth and not having all
of their stuff taken to the north of the
Roman territory Saturn of the client
state the Brigantes who were led by the
Queen Katia Mantua and were responsible
for protecting the Empire's northern
border from Raiders the lands conquered
by Rome were governed by two
administrators the first was the
governor who is in charge of military
and judicial matters and the second was
the procurator who is in charge of
economic ones
both reported directly to the Emperor
and was supposed to acts checks on each
other's ambitions and power the province
was wrong from camallo Dunham's now
called Colchester and was permanently
garrisoned by a Legion Rome slowly but
surely consolidated its hold upon
southern Britain but still had to
contend with the raids from the west and
the north in response to raiding in the
year 47 the Roman government made sure
to disarm all of their British subjects
which was in fact the law of the entire
empire in response the ice any revolted
but were quickly crushed importantly
around this time with the founding of
Londinium later London the next decade
saw a large-scale urbanization and the
beginning of a coin based economy as
opposed to the barter economy that had
preceded it camallo Dunham ballooned in
population as well as becoming a very
important Roman cultural center the
natives who lived under Roman rule was
subject to taxation of conscription as
well as discrimination these issues
eventually led to revolt in the year 60
the main catalyst for the revolt with
the death of Prasutagus who in his will
gave half of his kingdom to the new
emperor Nero and the other half to his
two daughters the Romans ignored this
and took everything the wife of
Prasutagus Boadicea protested this an in
return she was flogged and her daughters
were raped after this Boudicca raised
the Ionian revolt and was soon after
joined by the Treena vantes they
subsequently roamed southern Britannia
burning settlements such as camallo
Dunham's Londinium and Beryl our neom
now called st. Albans eventually
Boudicca clash with the governor of
Britannia Suetonius Paulinus at what is
known as the battle for Watling Street
the Romans of the 14th Legion were
heavily outnumbered but their better
organization tactics and equipment gave
them victory having lost Boudicca
committed suicide and after his
victories who Tonys went on a spree of
punitive expedition to destroy any
remnant of resistance to Roman rule the
new procurator krasiki Anna's believed
that this policy of murdering every
would cause more revolt and so the
Emperor Nero record suit oh nice aroma
and replaced him with a more tactful
governor the scars of the revolt began
to heal over the next decade with
Londinium and Camila Dunham being
rebuilt this process was cut short in
the Year 68 when crisis struck the Roman
Empire
Nero being largely useless was declared
an enemy of Rome and subsequently offed
himself
the next year known as the year of the
Four Emperors because shockingly there
were four Emperor's in the space of a
year plunged the Empire into chaos
whilst the Empire fell into said crisis
the Brigantes territory collapsed in
roman britain's northern border was
subject to intense raiding the chaos was
put to an end when Vespasian won the
Civil War and reunited the Empire and
was the first emperor of Rome second
major dynasty the Flavians
the return of stability meant the Rome
could now respond to the rage from the
north as well as consolidating their
hold over Britain in the late 70s Rome
was able to expand its control over the
island in part due to a man called
Agricola who would appointed governor of
Britannia in 77
he led several expeditions the first was
to crush the Brigantes and after that he
even advanced well into Caledonia
winning a major victory over the
Caledonians at the Battle of Mons Grau
pious thus most of Britain was under
Roman control but after Agricola was
recalled to Rome in 85 Caledonia swiftly
broke away from Roman influence so the
corporation of Britannia was achieved
via urbanization and the desire of
native British elites to become Roman
the public baths the Romans built meant
that those who used them could
distinguish themselves from the unwashed
barbarians from outside the Empire the
newly introduced Roman and Greek
literary classics could be read to show
off one's intelligence the new luxury
goods imported from the rest of the
Empire were a means of showing off
wealth as well it was through this
cultural pool factor the Rome was able
to incorporate the defeated elites into
the empire whom they often made
administrators this did not mean that
romanized natives were somehow seen as
equals by Romans and one such attitude
is displayed by the writer Tacitus who
was Agricola's son-in-law and is one of
the major sources for early Roman
Britain he says that within the British
a liking sprang up for our style of
dress and the toga became fashionable
all this in their ignorance they called
civilization when it was but a part of
their servitude one way of measuring
just how Roman the British natives have
become is by looking at religious belief
the Romans had a policy of incorporating
native gods into their own Pantheon for
example the goddess Sulis who was
worshipped at a place called Aquae Sulis
now called bath was
by the Romans to be the equivalent of
their goddess Minerva the goddess of
wisdom it is important to remember that
the building of towns and all of the
traditionally Roman things in them such
as baths and temples were almost always
paid for by the local elites not the
Emperor or the central Roman government
as far as these settlements go there
were four main types the first were the
Kolani I such as Linden Colonia
modern-day Lincoln which were the high
status wealthy centers which were where
military veterans and Roman citizens
were settled another type of Roman
settlement were the meanest appear the
only known one in Britain being very
Larned most of those that lived in
municipal were not Roman citizens though
the next with Sibbett our teas such as
corinne IAM now called cirencester which
were large romanized settlements of
conquered people finally were the wiki
which were small settlements that often
sprang up around Roman Garrison's to
benefit from trade with the army it
should be noted that most people living
in Roman Britain did not live in urban
centres between 80 and 90 percent of
people lived in rural areas with most
being peasant farmers these people did
not become romanized and life for them
changed little except for the fact that
they had large urban markets to sell
their excess crops to the amount of
effort put into Roman izing an
urbanizing Britain vary greatly over the
decades but one emperor who puts a great
deal of effort into promoting
development was Hadrian who actually
visited Britain in the year 122 Hadrian
paid for development in Londinium and an
attempt was made to drain part the fens
an area of swampland here in order to
increase arable land of course what
Hadrian is most famous for in Roman
Britain is Hadrian's Wall which started
construction in 122 and was completed in
128 there are a couple of misconceptions
about this wall one it does not mark the
border between modern-day England and
Scotland and in fact all of it is in
England and two it was not designed to
keep everyone out but was a series of
border checkpoints through which traders
could travel providing they paid attacks
20 years later another wall was built to
the north of Hadrian's Wall the Antonine
wall which was mostly made of earth
shockingly the Antonine wall was built
during the reign of Antoninus pious
Hadrian successor the war was mainly for
publicity back in Rome was abandoned
shortly after its construction by
Antoninus his successor Marcus Aurelius
this was probably due to the fact that
the land between the Hadrian and
Antonine walls was barren and needed
expensive development in order to supply
the garrison there furthermore there was
also a major revolt south of Hadrian's
Wall in 158 which had to be suppressed
the fact that throughout the Roman
period Britain was never home to less
than
three legions roughly 15,000 men and
their auxiliaries is proof that rome
never managed to fully pacify
protagonist population after Marcus
Aurelius is death in 180 rule of the
Empire was left to his son Commodus who
was terrible not much happened in
Britain during his reign except for a
few legionary revolts and the
appointment of a man could pertain axe
to the governorship of Britain
so Commodus was assassinated in 192 was
succeeded by person axe who at the first
emperor in what is known as the year of
the five emperors because at this point
why not
the civil wars that took place during
this period saw the legions in britain
declare a man could Clodius happiness
emperor but ultimately he failed the
winner of this conflict was a man called
septimus severus who founded the severn
dynasty and is considered by some to be
the divide between the early roman
empire and the late which we'll get to
next week
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching there are some
recommended books in the description
below and if you have any questions feel
free to ask
you